[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hi, I/O Live.
It's Todd Kerpalman
And I am here
with Asad Naweed, who is a
software engineer on AR Core.
So Asad, what's new in the
world of augmented reality?
ASAD NAWEED: Hi, Todd.
So today at I/O,
we're announcing
two new features in AR code
that we're really excited about.
We are announcing Augmented
Images and Cloud Anchors.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK, those
sound very impressive,
but what are they?
What's Augmented Images?
ASAD NAWEED: So
Augmented Images is
a set of APIs inside AR Core
that allow developers to create
AR apps that can recognize
images in the real world,
and then anchor virtual
content with respect to them.
So if your app can recognize
an image that's, say,
this portrait up
here, then it can
make that image come to life,
and overlay virtual content
on top of that image, and make
it do interesting things that
weren't possible before.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
what kind of apps
do you see taking advantage
of Augmented Images?
ASAD NAWEED: One other thing
that I'm really passionate
about is education.
And children's
education, in particular,
you could create an app
that recognizes the images
in a children's storybook.
And if kids, previously,
when they're just
reading a storybook can
now point their cellphones
at the storybook, and
then see the story
come to life, on top of their
books, right there and then.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, let's
check out one of these demos
here.
ASAD NAWEED: Yeah.
So this is Augmented Images.
And we'll see that AR
Core finds this image
and then makes it come
to life like that.
TODD KERPELMAN: Whoa.
ASAD NAWEED: So this
is what I was talking
about when I meant immersive
experiences is that, as we move
the phone slightly at an
angle, we see that the 3D
model actually turns with us.
And if we end up
going a little closer,
we'll see that the effect
is much more pronounced.
You can actually take a look
at the structure of the cubes
as they are there.
And it's so much more immersive
than the standard 2D painting,
because now, you have this box
that's reaching into the wall.
And the image is
no longer there.
And it's actually
even superimposed
by this 3D model that's
dynamic and can move.
And I can get different
perspectives on it,
depending on where I am.
So yeah, that's what's
really exciting about this.
TODD KERPELMAN:
And is it a phone
with any special hardware,
any special features?
What is this that we're
looking at this on?
ASAD NAWEED: So this is just a
phone that's running AR Core.
And AR Core doesn't have any
specific hardware requirements,
short of maybe just a good
camera and a good gyroscope,
an accelerometer.
But that's about it.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
And here, we have
another augmented image.
Let's see what's going on here.
ASAD NAWEED: Yep.
So this is another image that
the app knows how to recognize.
And now that it's done
that, we can see what
grows as we move the phone up.
And this then grows
into a massive tree
that an artist has put
together that's rooted
at the augmented image.
So if you keep going
all the way up,
you'll see that it becomes
a really, really, really
nice tree.
And as you bring the
phone down, the tree
will automatically sink back
into the augmented image
that it detected.
So these are the kinds of
visual experiences and things
that come to life,
rooted at images,
that the app knows
how to recognize.
And that's what we're really
excited to see what developers
are going to do with.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow,
that is super cool.
I could actually just
stay here all day
and watch the tree
grow and shrink,
but I think I have
other interviews to do.
ASAD NAWEED: [LAUGHS] No, you're
more than welcome to come back
when you're done.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well, if you need
me, folks, I'll
be hanging out here making
augmented reality trees grow.
And then the second
piece of technology
you were talking about
were Cloud Anchors.
So what is that?
And what does that allow
me to do, as the developer?
ASAD NAWEED: Cloud Anchors
allow you to create and host
anchors, AR Anchors,
and share them
between different people
and different devices.
And that's really exciting
because then suddenly, you
have the ability to create
apps that two people can
use together to anchor
content in the world
and see where other people have
anchored content in the world,
as well.
One other thing that
we're really excited about
is that THE Cloud Anchors
are actually cross-platform.
We're also really
excited to announce
that anchors created
on AR Core devices
will also be recreateable on iOS
devices running AR Core on iOS.
And that opens up the door to
so many different possibilities
and a significantly
larger user base.
So now, iOS developers can
also use AR Core Cloud Anchors.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So basically, we are setting
up a multi-player game
where both devices, an
iOS and an Android device,
are agreeing on the same
augmented reality space
that they're sharing.
Is that basically
what's going on here?
ASAD NAWEED: Yes, that's exactly
what's going on here, Todd.
I have in my hand an iPhone
that's running AR Core on iOS.
And Brian has an Android device.
And we are going to play
the same game together.
And--
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
let's give this a try here.
ASAD NAWEED: Now that's-- you
can see right there is where
Brian has placed his board.
And I will place mine here.
And when I am ready,
we are now going
to play a game where I have to
fire onto Brian's light board.
And when I do that,
it effectively
lights Brian's board up.
And then, he has to
color all of my dots
before I manage to do
the same thing for him.
And he is seeing these boards
in the exact same place
that I'm seeing them in.
And I can see him
playing the game with me.
And the only reason why
this shared area experience
is possible is because of
the magic of Cloud Anchors.
Ooh.
So yeah, just to kind of
reiterate, this is an iPhone.
It's not an Android device.
And we do have AR Core Cloud
Anchors supported on both iOS
devices and Android devices.
And we're really excited
to see what developers
are going to do with this.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is super awesome.
I can't wait to play some
really fun, augmented reality
multi-player games
around my living room.
ASAD NAWEED: [LAUGHS]
Well, definitely, yeah.
It's a blast for everyone,
like the whole family.
Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh my
gosh, that was super cool.
If you want to see more
exciting videos like this one,
head on over to g.co/io/guide
for lots more videos featuring
me and the rest of
the I/O Live crew.
[MUSIC PLAYING]